It's going not even cellphones what's happening, isn't it?
Get my consciousness inside the boat. What do you see
barry!!!
need some progress
run mr.allen!
runnn
Special delivery
Wow super pregnant
Looks like you do about 21 days from tonight. I'd say someone who understands that time is precious and right now is all we've got
Bella totally speaking
Everybody is Charlie. We got a breakdown this flash finale footage
There's a new round of that flash ring giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
So let's just go through the footage as we see this now. She's not anywhere in the trailer here
Obviously she has something to do with Barry defeating the thinker because the Speed Force
Symbols that he was writing when he came out of the Speed Force are the same symbols that she was writing in
That little book the little book belongs to DeVoe
He was writing the symbols on his blackboard right after he became the thinker so all three of these characters are
connected through the Speed Force symbols coffee girl is
connected now in addition to ways because the same symbols that Barry was writing but also she
Possesses the physical journal that belonged to devote that Marlies was thumbing through a couple episodes ago
So that will be key to whatever Barry does inside this mine space in rescuing everyone and saving the world
There's not a whole lot of season 5 teaser stuff in this trailer
But they always tease what's happening at the beginning of season 5 in the finale. So just be aware of that
We've talked about who the villain might be. I've seen a lot of new theories, too
So I'll address that when I post my finale video, but there'll be some more DC posting later this week
So maybe I'll do another video for that
But obviously we get that very comic book II moment that we've been waiting for since they announced that the thinker was going to be
a comic book villain on the flash TV show
so if you're not a big comic book reader in the
comics when the flash the Wally West flash fought Geoff Johns version of the thinker there was this famous panel with all these wires sticking
In his head, so within the issue which is actually titled crossfire part 3 the thinking man
So it's part of this larger thinker arc
Wally West learns it the only way that he can beat the thinker is by giving himself
Over to him so he's kind of more of a tech based villain and he's looking for more processing power
So he sort of absorbing the city. He's making it part of himself
So the flash literally has the fastest mind alive, which makes it the fastest computer alive on the planet
That's why the thinker wanted him so Wally West gives himself over
So the thinker sticks all of his tendrils in his head and briefly
until the flash can fight him within his mind space like something out of
Inception or going back even further the matrix I've been using the matrix is a more apt description
If you want to read that volume its flash vol 2 number 186, but it's part of the larger crossfire arc
So I would recommend you read that it has a me net black a lot of the stuff that they adapted for this season
But obviously they changed a lot of it for the TV show
So you can see why they probably did things this way instead of having the thinker just like put his hand with the tendril in
It on top of Barry's head and take him into his mind that way they want the Flash's
Personality within Devoe's mind to be free of devote and when he takes somebody like when he took Ralph they become part of him
So it's a little bit different
there's not like somebody running around inside your mind, but when they were filming this episode a couple weeks ago people were like
How come we're seeing the pudgy?
Version of Ralph on the set the one from before he became a hero and got his powers near the bus
So the whole idea is is that Barrie probably?
Encounters some of the bus metas as he runs through Davos mind Ralph's being one of them
I don't know if he's gonna rescue all the bus metas wise inside his mind here
But the producers teased a very inception II finale this is where they get to
Inception him actually going inside his mind now
I figure that they would do this when they announced the thinker as a villain because it's one of the most iconic
Geoff johns wally west comic book panels the flash doing the thinking man with all those wires sticking out of his head
But they changed so much about the comic book storyline that you just don't know until you actually see it
So when wally west flash fought the thinker inside his mind space it was a very similar
situation where wally went full matrix and realized that there were no
Limitations he could manifest anything that he wanted to so because it was the wally west version of the flash
He cloned a bunch of different versions of him from different eras in the comics
So all these different versions of the flash you see fighting the thinker here
These are just different versions of wally west from different eras
So you have the really young kid flash wally west in the yellow costume
You have him in the even earlier red costume before he got the yellow costume
So you just get the idea there inside a matrix like mine space. There are no limitations
You can manifest anything that your mind can come up with
So I'll be interested to see what he manifests to try and help him fight to vote inside the mind space
Obviously the other big storyline while Barry's inside the thinker's mind space is all this chaos with the Enlightenment
Happening in the real world. You see the skies are completely purple with like this really twisted aurora borealis
Like it's gonna be raining down Dark Matter on everyone really soon Joe makes a brief reference to just everything going crazy
You see Cisco outside their fires being lit people just going completely nuts
I love the fact that they're in jitters at the beginning of this trailer because we've all been talking about coffee girl and then as
Seal is getting ready to give birth
She has that little device on her forehead to prevent her from entering other people's minds. That was the old-school inhibitor
You see the real-life version of devote walked past her looking at her as she's getting ready to give birth
So it's like what does he want with?
Cecile or is he just coming for everyone because it sounds like this is all happening at STAR Labs like they brought
Cecile there instead of taking her to a traditional hospital, but they don't really give a whole lot else away besides Barry
Just trying to get used to what the mine space is
Like like it looks like he's getting his ass kicked
But this is probably right after he enters and he's not sure what's going on
I really love the way that he wakes up inside teuvos mine space at the scene of the crime
So to speak the scene where he exited the Speed Force and created all the bus Meadows in the way he sits up in frame
is like the way he sat up at the beginning of this season in the beginning of the pilot when he had been in a
Coma for a couple months
Hey Barry
It's me
So obviously we have to talk about the idea that the title is we are the flash and that's been a bit of a meme
Across the season it started way back I think in like the second episode or something like that
What iris said it the first time they brought it back around a couple more times?
Barry said it once when they were just working on a normal problem then now it sounds like they'll finally pay it off with Barry
Becoming part of the thinker we are the flesh so briefly
I think what will happen is is that the thinker will take over Barry while he's inside the mind space
Before Barry takes back over him
Remember the end of the Matrix Revolutions where he enters or allows Smith to absorb him then destroys Smith from the inside out
But it'll be really interesting to see how he tries to save the other bus medicine
that's like the other little hanging plot threat does everybody die because I think the idea is that they bring Ralph back at least so
I don't know if that means that they can also bring the other ones back too
We can talk about that one the episode actually happens because when he jumps into a new body, he effectively takes everything with him
So the old body is just a husk and what have they been doing with the old bodies
Did they put them on ice? Did they bury them?
Because it's been a couple months since he started jumping into other people's bodies going all the way back to the midseason finale
so they either got a whole bunch of popsicles in the fridge or it's gonna be some other really twisty
Explanation for how Ralph can come back out of DeVoe and still have a body
leave all your bonus video requests in the comments below and what will happen later today is as Marvel just confirmed that they were gonna
Be doing in eternals franchise during phase four. Now. They said franchise which means like a new trilogy
So it sounds like a pretty big thing. I'll do a video for that. There'll be more Deadpool to posting really soon
so be sure to go see the movie -
Congratulations to the giveaway winner for my last big video elliott guadarrama. Please private message me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner
When I post new DC click here for my flash video from last night and click here for my non-spoilery Deadpool 2 review
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight